paulo espino
34 year old right-hander 10th round pick
of the indians back in 2006.
two balls in a strike to rojas and
maggie rowe out toward left center field
this
is going to drop in a terrific effort by
roblaise but he comes up empty
and rojas starts tonight with a bloop
single
another fly ball to left center robles
goes back on this one toward the track
at the wall and he'll catch it on a lead
that one just kept traveling
victor robles knew he had room went up
and made a nice play
jumps up against the wall good job at
getting it in because rojas was tagging
he got about halfway to second hit the
brakes
0-1 pitch to marte is grounded up the
middle that's a base hit
roja stops at second marlins have a
couple of knocks here in the first
against espino
fastball popped up turner settles under
it
now in there's a second out
fastball drilled up the middle escobar
picks it nicely on the backhand
and paulo espino is out of the top of
the first
inning for the marlins it's trevor
rogers an all-star this year his 19th
start of 2021
02 to escobar this one grounded to 30
santiagos
makes the play a little bit wide but
aguilar applied the tag
right back to rogers off the bat of
turner
and aguilar steps on the bag two way
this is a bouncer to third diaz throws
across the diamond
right on the bag this time and rogers
works around the wall
swinging a miss curveball for
espino's first strikeout of the ball
game 2-1
is laced out to right center field
that's going to get down and sierra can
run this will be too
easily he is going to stop right there
though
that fastball by him for strike three
josh harrison struck well out to left
bad route out there by sierra
ball gets by him didn't even touch it on
the way by josh harrison will cruise
into second base
and i don't know if sierra thought that
he was looking at the lights maybe and
all of a sudden the ball went by him
victor robles one for two career against
trevor rogers with a double
left center field and down bob headley
is going to wave home josh harrison
here's the throw it's up the line
robles will go for second
he and josh harrison trade places the
nationals
have a one-nothing lead here in the
second
good slider from espino for strike three
here's that shutdown inning
fp was talking about soto on it first
he's reached in 16 of his 22 played
appearances
since the all-star break but he is
stranded at first base and zimmerman
strikes out
right side fair ball
more offense from tres pereira little
two out double
another strikeout for rogers able to
strand a couple
the 3-2 ground ball right to trey
paolo espino five scoreless here tonight
how about the national starters in this
series first leicester
now espino
and drills this one to right paul was
smoked on an o2 count
let's see if ryan can do a little
two-out damage here he had some good
hacksas
last time up zimmerman center field
marte can't get to this one turner is
flying around
third ryan zimmerman a two out
rbi double has doubled the nationals
lead here in the fifth
and when you see a guy hit for so many
years you know when all the moving parts
are on time but watch
the hands back the leg kick nice and
early
and so trey turner get on your horse
baby
[Applause]
right about here he knows maybe i'll
turn around a little bit because i got a
score here
now i could decelerate flaps down foam
on the runway two out double by ryan
zimmerman two to nothing
paulo espino had three k's in his five
scoreless and now he hands things over
to austin vote marte
base hit left field diaz will stop at
second marlins
off to a good start here in the sixth
inning second hit tonight for marte
pretty good opportunity here trying to
break through for the first time tonight
trailing by a pair in the sixth inning
adam duvall this one's hit deep and it's
gonna go
way out over the marlins bullpen
three-run home run adam duvall and that
is the hit the marlins needed
now the big guy does it again how many
times have we seen him come through with
a
big swing particularly with a couple of
guys on
there goes tres pereira yet again it's
another extra base
hit for the nationals catcher
back to back doubles to right fields
this guy can't be stopped
it'll be yadiel hernandez now with two
outs
it goes the other way and it falls in
fair territory
yadiel hernandez a big pinch hit rbi
double here in the sixth this ball
game's tied
this one got him
marlins are asking for an appeal to see
if he swung first base umpire corey
blazer said he didn't
but davey martinez much more concerned
about the health
of al-sadi's escobar right now better
than the right arm
the back arm maybe back elbow funny bone
[Applause]
and he's going to come out of the game
[Applause]
trey turner right field the nationals
take the lead right back
turner plates hernandez it's a 4-3 nats
lead
juan soto with runners at the corners
1-2 drilled to the left side and through
juan soto beats the shift and gives the
nationals another run trey turner first
to third
the line is moving here with two outs in
the six
squibs this one to the right side
harrison will charge
one two three seventh inning put up by
kyle finnegan
josh bell to left field has he homered
in back-to-back games he sure has
from the right side yet again
josh bell goes yard and it's a three run
nationals lead here in the eighth
and number 100 for his career
brad hand on to try and shut it down
fastball there's harrison
then that's wrapped this one up six to
three is the final
brad hand his 20th save of the season
the nationals have won three straight